well if senator Elizabeth Warren runs
for president in 2020 and a lot of us
are rooting for that because we believe
in diversity
you can bet you're gonna hear a lot more
of president Trump's nickname for her
Pocahontas Warren says that nickname is
racist but a direct descendent of
Pocahontas who you're about to meet does
not agree
Debbie white Perico says she can trace
her lineage right back to Pocahontas and
she is a challenge for Senator Warren to
be pre-cleared sister Debbie thank you
for coming on it's nice to see you thank
you so what is your challenge
first well we're honored - what's your
challenge for Senator one well my
challenge would be that I don't know
where she's how she's saying Pocahontas
is a racial slur Pocahontas is a real
person well it seems like a compliment I
mean when when people point out that
you're related to Pocahontas do you take
offense no I don't I don't I'm proud I
was in a restaurant the other day and in
Palm Beach and I was leaving with
someone and the person said oh you're
with Pocahontas it wasn't offensive to
me at all I was proud that they said
that so how do you view Senator Warren's
claim that she is an American Indian do
you believe her well I respect Senator
Warren as a u.s. senator but I just wish
you take the DNA test and if she took
the DNA test then that would end a lot
of this controversy yeah and if she was
part American Indian I'd be the first
one to welcome her into our heritage
well amen maybe she's related to
Pocahontas - I mean weirder things have
happened why do you think she won't take
the DNA test it doesn't cost much
I know I know maybe she's afraid she's
not you know it's it's not right it
I mean it's offensive that she doesn't
take it but yeah you can't you know make
somebody take something if they don't
want to no of course she can't but if
she were here you would encourage her to
take the DNA test oh yes
yes I would
good well she may run for president you
may have other opportunities to
encourage her to do that and we hope you
all in fact we'll have you on just to
remind her if she runs and she may
Debbie it's great to see you okay
good to see you too tucker thanks have a
great night